y seguimos ya con los deportes aquí en
directo de América de France 24 después
de este repaso a la salud vamos a hablar
ahora de deportes olímpicos con eumar
esa hay es que el olimpismo está
enfrentando en las últimas semanas luego
de que el comité olímpico interseccional
recomendar a la readmisión de los
atletas rusos y bielorrusos está
enfrentando una grave división a pesar
de que la guerra en Ucrania está lejos
de terminar como digo con nuestra
compañera eumanesa vamos a hablar de
esto con nuestro segundo invitado del
día porque la decisión Además del comité
olímpico internacional estaba basada en
un informe del relator especial de las
Naciones Unidas sobre racismo y
discriminación que sugería la
participación como atletas neutrales lo
han rechazado los aliados de Ucrania
pero también los comités Olímpicos de
Rusia y velarus que consideran
inaceptable competir sin sus banderas en
días recientes las grima ha cancelado al
menos cinco eventos debido a los
obstáculos que han puesto los gobiernos
de los países organizadores Para emitir
las visas a los competidores de estas
nacionalidades con Jorge Hernán Peláez
columnista del diario La República y
director de alparredón vamos a ahondar
en esta problemática Jorge Hernán
Bienvenido a France 24 Quiero
preguntarle estamos ante una nueva forma
de injerencia política en el deporte
Rodrigo buenos días y gracias a ustedes
y a todo el equipo de France 24 por la
invitación nuevamente
Qué bueno poder estar con ustedes para
hablar de este tema que ya se empieza
empieza a ventilar y va a ser muy
próximo verano porque recordemos que los
Juegos Olímpicos son en París el año
2024 creo que para contestar la pregunta
debemos hacer de pronto un contexto
histórico muy rápido diciendo que pues
esta no es la primera vez
parece que estamos
parece que está primero los problemas de
los años 1980 y 1984 donde estábamos en
la guerra fría y fueron desarrollados en
Moscú y Los Ángeles
respectivamente Fueron boicoteados por
la unión soviética para no ir a Los
Ángeles y fueron boicoteados por Estados
Unidos para no éramos
una decisión de país una decisión de
estado
deportistas claro por fuera en esas
competiciones digamos emblemáticas
hasta haber entrado el pedazo final del
siglo pasado Sudáfrica estuvo sancionada
por las Naciones Unidas por el tema de
la parte recordemos que posterior a eso
Sudáfrica organizó mundial de fútbol
liberar liberaron a Nelson Mandela y
digamos que estableció nuevas relaciones
sus vecinos Pero ellos estuvieron
bloqueados políticamente de todas las
competencias no solo olímpicas sino
también de otras disciplinas esta
decisión de sacar a Rusia viene desde el
fútbol la FIFA lo saca la eliminatoria
al Mundial de Qatar de la UEFA lo sacan
de las competencias de Champions League
UEFA Europa lea los clubes rusos y
después viene todo el tema de comité
olímpico no es la primera vez que
o sea ahora lo que pasa es que son todos
va a estar ahí Rodrigo porque
estamos teniendo problemas técnicos con
nuestro invitado parece que no se le
escucha bien eumar Este es un tema muy
interesante del que esperamos poder
seguir hablando hoy con nuestro invitado
de momento Omar tú eres bastante
entendida en este tema eres nuestra
experta en juegos olímpicos Cómo se ha
creado esta polémica veníamos hablando
estos días de la esgrima también del
boxeo que es lo que está pasando en esos
deportes en el boxeo Se ha producido un
cisma una división que es un hecho
totalmente inusitado no se ha dado en
ninguna federación internacional en toda
la historia ahora ha habido un grupo una
la disidente que luego de la decisión de
la asociación internacional de boxeo de
admitir a los rusos y bielorrusos con su
bandera en el campeonato mundial de
Nueva Delhi han decidido montar digamos
tienda aparte crear lo que se llama
World boxing un organismo internacional
independiente y recordemos que esto es
súper delicado para el olimpismo una de
los obstáculos para que el karate do
entrara a los juegos de Tokio fue la
necesidad de que se unificaran todas
esas organizaciones y distintos estilos
que regían este deporte a nivel mundial
esa unidad es sumamente importante para
que un deporte sea reconocido por el
comité olímpico internacional y mantenga
su haga su vida dentro de la
organización dentro del deporte
organizado voluntario esto por una parte
hablabas también del tema del esgrima se
han cancelado dos torneos satélites se
han cancelado Dos copas del mundo y todo
esto por la participación o la
perspectiva la participación de los
rusos yo quería ya que hemos recuperado
a nuestro invitado quería plantearle
otro de las grandes dudas que surgen con
esta situación de los atletas de la
incorporación de estos atletas uno de
los argumentos que citan los que se
oponen a la participación de ruso de los
rusos en la competencia Es que muchos de
los atletas de ese país tienen grados
militares lo que significaría para los
atletas ucranianos en caso de un
eventual enfrentamiento estar chocando
contra digamos un miembro de un ejército
Invasor cómo funciona esta
asimilación o este este otorgamiento de
grados militares a través del deporte
pues obviamente en el caso de Rusia como
usted lo menciona no solamente los
deportistas los empresarios y gente
influyente de ese país ha estado
obligada al gobierno de Putin porque
realmente hemos visto que es un gobierno
que tiene un apoyo de cierta parte de la
población muy cínicativo y de eso es lo
que lo ha mantenido en el poder entonces
eh yo siento que también hay que
involucrar algo que está pasando ahora
en las redes sociales con los
deportistas y en todas las competencias
y que no ha sido regulado Y es que los
deportistas sus familias sus
entrenadores todo el equipo cercano
busca que el deportista pues promueva
sus temas deportivos en sus redes pero
muchos de ellos los utilizan sabiendo
que tiene tanto tráfico como activismo
para temas políticos estamos viendo
activismos por la comunidad lgbt por el
tema del aborto que ustedes tocaban hace
unos minutos es decir el deportista hace
algunos años se dio cuenta que tiene la
capacidad de influir mucho en los
seguidores y ha habido muchos depor
europeos que desde el principio cuando
se invadió Ucrania han rechazado el tema
entonces siento que es por ahí donde el
comité olímpico quiere que sean los
mismos deportistas los que digan si
quieren que los rusos participen Sin
Bandera y sin uniforme o que si los
deportistas no están de acuerdo sean
ellos los que tomen la decisión porque
el comité olímpico sabe que donde tome
una decisión para un lado o para el otro
la marea de redes sociales va a ser
Incontenible y ellos lo que no quieren
es que los Juegos Olímpicos se vuelvan
tendencia que sean virales por eso sino
justamente lo están haciendo un año
antes no solo para que los deportistas
se puedan preparar si es que los van a
dejar y además logren llegar de una
manera medianamente competitiva sino
también Para ir preparando el ambiente y
yo siento que si va a haber estas
próximas semanas una marea de redes
sociales con numerales y tendencias
probablemente el comité olímpico va a
parar el tema y va a dejar los rusos por
fuera
pues es muy interesante este tema un mal
que nos Comenta nuestro invitado además
es difícil también que muchas veces los
atletas rusos se pronuncien en contra de
su propio gobierno por las consecuencias
que esto Podría tener para sus familias
dentro de Rusia
hay ejemplos Pues de los que han sido
opositores a Putin que no han terminado
bien y han terminado Viviendo por fuera
de Rusia exilados y pues está el caso
del espía ruso que fue envenenado en
Londres Así que se parte de un supuesto
Y es que el gobierno ruso a sus
opositores pues no los va a frenar de
una manera amistosa y va a intentar
hacer cualquier cosa para que eso pues
no suceda adicionalmente está Pues todo
el tema de la forma como Rusia ha venido
ingiriendo en redes sociales por ejemplo
para el tema de la política en Estados
Unidos es decir hay hackers rusos y hay
compañías y bodegas rusas dedicadas
exclusivamente a atacar a las personas
en redes sociales Entonces tampoco Nadie
quiere agarrarse contra eso